[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat nous parlerons ce soir du manque
de professeurs dans le second degré un
certain nombre de postes seraient encore
vacants dans les yvelines
c'est la fcpe la fédération des conseils
de parents d'élèves qui continue de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé alors que
l'année scolaire est bien avancé il
manquerait encore une cinquantaine de
professeurs dans le seul département des
yvelines
une situation jugée pire que celle des
années précédentes et à laquelle a réagi
dès le mois d'octobre la ministre de
l'éducation nationale
najat vallaud belkacem elle a notamment
proposé un plan de cette mesure pour
améliorer le remplacement des
professeurs
mais comment expliquer la situation
quelle solution avec nous pour en
débattre françois andré président de la
fcpe des yvelines et rené matheron
directeur académique adjoint à
l'académie de versailles bonsoir
monsieur onfray françois andré fêtant un
petit état des lieux aujourd'hui combien
de postes vacants dans les yvelines
et de quel type d'absence parle-t-on
alors la situation c'est évidemment
considérablement améliorée par rapport à
la rentrée scolaire nous nous avions
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé en septembre
puis à la toussaint parce que la
toussaint la crise était encore très
forte
il ya eu une forte réaction ensuite
entre la toussaint et noël pour essayer
de combler et nous avons fait un point
rapide pour cette rentrée
on est descendu pour notre dans notre
cas a encore une vingtaine de points
noirs dans recensés par notre base de
données où il n'ya pas cours c'est une
base déclarative donc c'est sur la base
des parents d'élèves fcpe qui sont dans
ces établissements qui nous renseigne en
permanence et qui met à jour notre
fichier mais évidemment la réalité bien
sûr c'est un chiffre par défaut puisque
c'est du déclaratif et qu'on n'a pas de
parole parce que non plus dans le
département donc une vingtaine vous
dites aujourd'hui mais on est passé à
des tic
on a eu 240 dossiers d'ouvert depuis le
début de l'année très bien
rené macron
les parents qui nous regardent doivent
se dire au mois de janvier on en est
encore là mais surtout comment peut-on
démarrer une année scolaire avec des
profs non quand bien on va essayer
d'expliquer
d'abord il faut dire que les parents
d'élèves sont inquiets de voir des profs
manquants et nous nous sommes inquiets
aussi non effectivement monsieur andré
le disais on déploie des efforts assez
considérable au niveau académique et au
niveau départemental pour pourvoir les
postes manquants
donc je crois que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de faire effectivement un état des
lieux de voir où on en est aujourd'hui
essayez de dévaluer d'où on vient et
puis de d'expliquer la situation c'est
de comprendre ce qui fait que nous en
sommes là aujourd'hui
alors qu'andré disait il on recense les
parents d'élèves ont recensé une
vingtaine de situations aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui encore tout à fait on n'est
pas en désaccord globale sur le chiffre
rond pourraient ils se disent les autres
on à l'envi sur un tel ou tel
pour ce qui nous concerne nous nous
avons actuellement exactement 27
situation dans le département qui reste
difficile alors que même cette situation
ça peut vouloir dire un prof manquants
ça peut vouloir dire trois heures dans
un établissement des heures dans un
autre parce que justement allez y
messieurs
alors je ne sais pas on peut on peut
effectivement distinguer des situations
de vacances parce que le poste n'est pas
pourvus parce que l'enseignant est
malade mais au reste si l'enseignant
n'est pas là depuis le début de l'année
il est pas là ce soit pour une raison
pour une autre pour les parents et pour
les élèves
la situation reste la même c'est peu
dire dans les deux mais enfin je ne
pense pas que l'on parle pas d'une d'une
absence de volare ou de deux jours là on
parle d'absence d'une durée conséquente
nous allons créer qui peuvent émettre
des absences qui dure depuis le début de
l'année scolaire
mais nous m'avez rejet ou dans la base
de données que nous renseignons nous
avions de séparer les trois situations
de possibles soit un congé effectivement
de courte durée soit un prof qui n'a
jamais été nommé à la rentrée qui
n'était pas nommé dans sur lequel on
pouvait pas mettre de nom ou un non
remplacement d'un congé attendu par
exemple congés formation au congé
maternité
donc on s'est retrouvés de manière assez
inattendue un très grand nombre de types
d'absence de vacance de poste fait à
l'entrée alors monsieur mac ont
justement un prof qui n'est pas nommé
comment ça se fait qu'est ce qui se
passe au niveau du rectorat
alors on explique rapidement comment on
recrute les enseignants c'est le début
de ce début de la chaîne
oui le la le mode de recrutement
privilégié c'est le concours donc un
nombre de postes ouverts aux concours
compte tenu de ce que la ministre a avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement à augmenter
le nombre d'enseignants 60000 postes
sur le quinquennat c'est ses
conséquences comme nombre a donc
évidemment le besoin de recrutement
augmente on ajoute à ça que la
démographie du département des yvelines
est en croissance également qu'
effectivement on a eu des besoins très
importants sur les collèges et les
lycées en particulier sur le second
degré donc qui tient à la courbe
démographique ordinaire tout le monde
sait que aux environs de l'an 2000 il ya
eu de nombreuses naissances donc quand
on arrive en 2010 est évidemment on
arrive sur les premières et les
terminales l'année dernière c'était les
secondes qui était en très forte tension
mais l'absolu on a des estimations un
appartement dans l'ancien sur la dessus
il ya pas de problème et on peut façon
on peut facilement l'anticiper et pour
l'anticiper et bien on augmente le
nombre de postes aux concours d'accord
alors qu'on était à 93 cents je crois
exactement encore faut-il qu'ils soient
pourvus à 100% ses cotisants pour dion à
93%
ça veut dire qu'il ya 7 % qui sont pas
pourvus et c'est bien là qu'est le
problème parce que les 93 % personne ne
le voit c'est ce qu'ils sont recrutés
qui sont implantées et quand vous voyez
qu'on a 10 mille enseignants dans le
département dans le second degré à peu
près ben on en est aujourd'hui à 27 dont
vous voyez que c'est bien sûr cette
petite marge qui au plan statistique est
faible mais qui impactent fortement
certains établissements donc on a ce ce
phénomène de manque de candidats aux
concours
une fois que on a constaté qu'on manque
est candidat au concours on procède à un
recrutement de professeurs contractuels
alors pour essayer d'anticiper les
choses
le rectorat aujourd'hui fait des
contrats de deux ans ce qui fait qu'on a
comme ça des gens qui sont installés
deux ans renouvelable évidemment mais
qui sont garanties d'emploi pendant au
moins 2 années ce qui fait qu'on a un
vivier permanent et il peut arriver
c'est ce qui s'est produit cette année
que ce vivier ne suffisent pas encore et
que donc il faille avoir recours à de
nouveaux recrutements
donc faut trouver des candidats la
difficulté il restera dans la rime ça ne
se trouve pas que les revues bon je vous
interromps juste pour préciser des
parents d'élèves
vous l'aviez cité avait même déposé des
annonces sur des sites internet etc pour
là on est allé loin quoi pour recruter
des professeurs comme ça sans réelle
vocation s'établissement demande aussi
pour certains pas tous mais certains
chefs d'établissement demande aux
parents d'élèves de les aider à détecter
des candidats vacataires enfin
contractuels en l'occurrence c'est nous
on n'est pas très favorable à ce système
ne s'improvise pas professeur et il nous
faut il faut reconstituer ce vivier de
remplaçants qui a totalement disparu par
des gens par des professionnels par des
gens qui savent tenir une classe sont
pas les contractuels même pas des
contractuels
on aimerait bien qu'on fasse beaucoup
moins appel à des contractuels récent ce
que vous pointez françois andres et que
c'est personnes contractuels n'ont pas
forcément l'entousiasme où la force de
on fait des difficiles recrutement déjà
délicat on demande quand même un certain
niveau je suis pas certain que les
conditions de salaire soit attractive
mais en plus on peut intervenir sur
plusieurs départements et on arrive dans
un métier qui encore une fois demande de
la formation nous on avait été quand
même les premiers on vit les effets pas
seulement des suppressions de postes d
année 2008 à 2012 mais aussi de la
suppression des iufm
c'est d'ailleurs de là suppression de la
formation initiale et ça ça a été ça a
mis du temps à revenir à se remettre en
place les espèces seraient en vitesse de
croisière mais la formation initiale
elle n'est pas encore complètement
points donc non seulement on a on a
puisé dans le vivier de remplaçants pour
essayer d'occuper des postes de
titulaires mais en plus on a du mal à
former la cohorte qui suit donc on est
en panne de vrais professeurs en faites
pas on peut toujours trouver des
contractuels mais s'il craque au bout
d'une semaine ou quinze jours et ce qui
a été dit dans plusieurs médias des
situations qui en fait se répète
eh bien ça ne sert à rien c'est pas la
peine de passer du temps à recruter des
contractuels s'y tienne ben ali alors la
ministre vous a un peu entendu rené mack
roux est là en octobre dernier proposé
un plan de cette mesure est ce que vous
êtes en train de le mettre en place
c'est un plan qui voit là vise à
améliorer le remplacement dernier de
changer il ya plusieurs choses là si
vous voulez bien tout d'abord j'arrive à
avoir des accords écrits en dresser
fréquemment sur le fait que la formation
soit pas encore au point je peux tout à
fait d'accord parce que les espèces ont
pas totalement naissant quand même et
aujourd'hui on a un dispositif de
formation qui existe
alors il est vrai que comme tout système
maintenant à partir du moment où vous
construisez de la formation cela demande
du temps ça ça ne s'improvise pas on
peut pas du jour au lendemain
avoir totalement terminé une formation
dont il ya du temps il ya des modalités
de recrutement de y compris de
prérecrutement aujourd'hui puisqu'un
certain nombre de
de nos professeurs sont actuellement
recrutés avant même d'être titulaire
d'un master par le biais de dispositifs
qui permettent de les prix recruter
donc il ya effectivement un système de
formation je reconnais qu'il ya mis du
temps à se mettre en place mais c'est
une réalité qui a dû être effectivement
reconstruit à partir des anciens iufm de
non respect donc tout ça est en train de
se mettre en place et aujourd'hui abouti
mais le fait qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
abouti ne produit pas un nombreuses chez
migros qui a forcément un effet il ya
forcément un effet retard on this
produits et comme cet effet retard et
conjuguer avec un effet démographique
très favorable c'est-à-dire positif ce
qui est le cas à la fois du département
des yvelines de tous les départements de
de la région par la région parisienne
ont pas laissés prendre
on comprend bien que il ya forcément un
délai la deuxième chose c'est que il a
été évoqué la question des annonces on
passe des petits talents de conseils
vrai qu'on passe pas des petites
annonces directement nous on travaille
avec pôle emploi qui effectivement est
l'organisme qui est en mesure de repérer
parmi les les deux vendeurs d'emploi
actuels ceux qui souhaiteraient devenir
enseignant et par ce biais c'est vrai
qu'on recrute des gens de catégorie très
différentes
vous avez 2 à mes étudiants fraîchement
sorti de l'université qui a priori
n'avait pas pensé à devenir enseignant
et puis qui parfois pressé par le besoin
matériel ces gens cherchent du travail
c'est un c'est un métier dont il est
légitime que que certains souhaitent
l'exercer et puis vous avez aussi des
des nouveaux collègues qui font de
seconde carrière qui ont déjà lu un
métier antérieurement et qui cherche le
vertige convertir vers un professeur
voilà donc on a des viviers
effectivement rien jamais ne garantit le
jour de l'embauché et malgré
les contrôles effectués auprès des
candidats et malgré des entretiens
qu'ils font et malgré les éléments de
formation qu'on apporte je ne vais pas
dire que nous faisons une formation des
personnels recrutés sur des contrats de
vacation mais on est on est pas dans les
classes directement quand même et on a
d'ailleurs organisé puisque ce phénomène
existe aussi dans le premier degré il
n'y a pas que que dans le second degré
on organisait évidemment des temps de
stage de ces personnes donc le temps de
guerre écoutait le temps qu'il soit en
stage auprès de professeurs titulaires
et qu'ils puissent effectivement pendant
une classe l'espace du temps alors c'est
ce qui explique d'ailleurs que comme le
disait monsieur andré le déclenchement
de l'arrivée des processeurs s'est
plutôt fait après les congés de tout ça
c'est pas parce qu'on avait pas prêté
avant c'est parce qu'il faut le temps de
les écouter de les aider à culture est
un peu a lancé bien connu un départ
anticipé par ailleurs par ailleurs ils
sont ils sont suivis ils sont suivis par
ailleurs par des conseillers
pédagogiques
au cours de leur première année
d'exercice
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive
à maîtriser encore une fois là où
vraiment nous avons une difficulté c'est
que dans ces cas là dans certaines
disciplines on a du mal à trouver les
candidats alors c'est le terreau des
langues vivantes en espagnol en anglais
c'est le cas de la technologie c'est les
3 matières pour lesquelles on a le plus
de difficultés actuellement à trouver
des candidats à partir du moment où on a
trouvé les candidats ont cédé recruter
merci rené macro françois andré vingt
trois mots de conclusion
d'abord
nous on estime qu'il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation réel pour cette rentrée
2016 on s'attendait surtout côté enfin
du côté des parents d'élèves on pensait
que la difficulté serait dans les
langues à cause de la réforme des
collèges et la ministre avait annoncé
que sa réforme coûtera entre 0 et 4000
postes on conseille pas très bien
combien de centaines de postes sur notre
académique est très grande mais on a été
très surpris par l'ampleur de des
vacances de postes dans les matières
scientifiques par exemple donc là on a
un problème de fond qui qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas nouveau qui n'est pas réglée
et nous nous inquiétons énormément de la
prochaine rentrée 2010 est parce que si
on en est encore aujourd'hui à essayer
de recruter les actuels titulaires
on n'a toujours pas de vivier de
remplaçants et en plus parmi les actuels
contractuels y en a qui renouvelleront
pas leur contrat donc on aura à nouveau
la difficulté de recruter
donc il faut quand même qu'on arrive à
prendre le taureau par les cornes et
qu'on assure aux parents d'élèves
en tout cas pour les yvelines que la
rentrée 2010 est se passera dans de bien
meilleures conditions que celles de 2016
alors la ministre a prévu notamment 1500
postes de remplaçants nouveaux qui
seront créés au niveau national espérons
que ça apporte une réponse c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui merci messieurs très
bonne soirée à vous tous
[Musique]